Let's take a closer look at how naming base
redirection works. In the example shown here, I've looked up
symantec.com from two different locations. You can see that
when we look up the domain name, we don't get
an A record immediately, but rather we get a
CNAME or a canonical name. Which tells us to look
up the following domain name in Akamai. When we look
up that domain name, we see, two corresponding IP addresses.
Notice that when we perform the same look
up from Boston, we also get redirected to Akamai
through the CNAME, but we get, two different IP
addresses, that are presumably more local to the Boston
area. So depending on where the client looks
up the domain name, it recieves different IP addresses
at different locations in the network. This is how
operators use DNS to redirect clients to nearby replicas.
As another example,you can see when I ping youtube.com,
I get very low latencies. And when I do
a reverse lookup on this IP address, I in
fact see that the content was posted on Google CDN.